اهلا وسهلا على مدار رمضان رافقكم تفاعلكم
في موسم استثنائي من كل النواحي اولا لانه
لاول مره طلينا عليكم لمده ساعه كامله على
الهواء مباشره وثانيا بسبب موعدنا الرمضان
اللي هو 12 بتوقيت السعوديه واللي بنطل
عليكم فيه اليوم لاخر مره في هذا الموسم
قبل ما نرجع لموعدنا المعتاد اللي هو سته
مساء وثالثا لانه حقيقه كان موسم درامي
استثنائي وغني ومختلف ومليء بالاعمال
الضخمه وبالجدل كمان ومثل كل سنه تفاعلكم
راح يختم معكم حلقات الموسم الرمضاني
بحلقه بنسميها احنا بيننا وبين بعض في
فريق العمل جردت الشهر فخليني معاكم
اعزائي المشاهدين بنجرد هذا الشهر وانا من
كم ثانيه كنت بقول لكم انه كان في موسم
حافل بالاعمال الدراميه نتكلم عن عشرات
عشرات الاعمال الدراميه وهذا الدليل
بسم الله نبدا الموسم سر الباتع من في سر
الباتع وفي مسلسل سر الباتع سر الباتع ايش
العوده من مسلسل المتمرد في سفر بربر كتبه
ابريل رساله الامام لرساله الامام رساله
الامام استوديو 23 وسقط سهوا سوق الكانتول
مسلسل عمله نادر عمله نادره وعمله نادره
صندوق عشره عمر هو مسلسل دفعه لندن الدفعه
لندن دفعه لندن دفعت لندن دفعه لندن دفعه
لندن الصفاره عود سخيه للنار بالنار مسلسل
النار بالنار والنار بالنار والهرجه
السابعه في الهرش السابعه مسلسل واخيرا
بين صبايا وجلطه مسلسل الازهر منه ولدنا
اثنين وفي منه ولدنا اثنين وجعفر العمده
جعفر العمده جعفر العمده مسلسل جعفر
العمده الى جعفر العمده في جعفر العمده
وبين العمده والصندوق مسلسل قط احمر عن
الزند بالعاصي وسفر في حياه المثاليه
مسلسل النون وما يعلمون مسلسل ضرب نار
ومسلسل ستهم ستهم بستهم تلت التلاته الف
الف حمد لله على السلامه
كل هذه الاعمال اتكلمنا عنها وكثار من
نجومها نورونا كمان في تفاعلكم السنه
نورنا فيها اربعه واربعين نجم ونجمه هذه
تحيه منا لهم جميعا
وينضم الينا النجم احمد فهمي العروس مريتا
النجم خالد المظفر الفنانه ميلا الزهراني
كل عام وانت بالف خير ماجد النجمه هند
نزار فيكي معانا ما يفن نجم احمد
اليماني الفنان هشام عاشور الممثله رولا
عادل شكرا لك يا ابراهيم المخرج الكبير
خالد يوسف الفنانه ليلى عبد الله النجم
المخرج محمد
من بيروت النجمه ورد الخال النجم القدير
محمود البزاوي نجمه روجينا ادم الشرقاوي
الاعلام العراقي احمد البشير اهلا فيك
معانا يا احمد ناصر الدوسري اهلا فيك
معانا يا ناصر شكرا لك يا هاله على وقتك
اليوم الفنان طوني عيسى اهلا فيك معنا
ميونه وحشتيني الشاعر الممثل نقول الان
هشام نجمه جاني اسبر الفنان فايز بن جريس
الفنانه ناهد السباعي النجمه اسماء جلال
الاستوديو من بعد طول انتظار النجمه على
المطاوع اهلا فيك يا حنان النجم جورج شكرا
النجم الكبير عبد الله
المخرج النجم محمد سامي اهلا فيك يا محمد
تحيه من القلب حقيقه لكل اللي نورونا
وفعليا استمتعنا بكل مقابله معاهم وللمانه
يعني المقابلات كان فيها كثير من الضحك
اكيد انت الحبيب حتكون حتقول انت المؤلف
والمنتج والم
اكيد يعني طبعا هتزبط الامور انه كل
البنات تحبك انت اكيد يعني خلص مفهومه
تمام مره كنت في هذا الجواب يا خالد
لا هذه الاسئله خليها بخمسه وعشرين سؤال
ههه
ما توقعت لدرجه انه في في في وقت ما شفت
كاميرات وعرفت انه مقلب بس ما توقعت انه
رامز اوكي بس كان نفسي اضربه بصراحه يعني
خلاص
كذا بعدين يقولوا السعوديات ما يضربوا ما
ياخذوا حقكم يعني شوفي هو جاهل اللي جاه
بس يعني كان ودي اكثر بالضبط
يعني نقطه ضعف بصراحه
مش معقوله ايدك يعني بتشيل على طول يعني
وبتحطه وبتخبي سرقتي كل المسلسل ايش الوضع
معك خافي على نفسك لحسن
اهلا وسهلا سوزي
سلمي يا سوزي خلينا الله
سلمي يا سوزي طيب سوزي كتكوته سوزي
صغيره بالتوفيق في علاقتك قصه حبك مع سوزي
ان شاء الله يعني تكبروا سوا
السنه الجايه وهي سنه واربع شهور تكون ان
شاء الله
شكرا لك يا ساره وتشرفت بالمقابله دي
ودائما المقابله بتكون يعني والله انت
اللي وشك حلو عليا مش انا
اللي فاتت يعني يا رب دايما نعملها عاده
وتكون سوزي كبرت بقى رمضان جاي تيجي معنا
[ضحك]
تعال
وا ايش سر الوضع
ايش صار يعني خليني اقول انا اقول لك انا
فعليا فعليا من الناس اللي حب شعري فابغى
اشوف اي طريقه الام مو غير اني احلقه لانه
ما شاء الله لما يكون واقف كانه ياشر من
بعيد
قلت خلاص تمام
يلا
اكيد اكيد
[ضحك]
ان ما عندناش قطن مصري انا عايز اعرف مين
بقى الجميل العظيم اللي قدر بقى يخش جوه
الشاشه ويمسك القماش كده ويقول لا والله
ده مش كتان ده قطن ده ازاي يعني احمد مظهر
ده طوله 165 سم
يعني حضرتك اطول منه
هو الحقيقه يعني يا خالد لو انت عرفت طول
الحقيقي ما كنت اقول الجمله هذه لانه احمد
مظهر اطول مني بكثير الحقيقه يعني الله
يرحمه
موضوع الجميله علشان الزملاء اللي بيشككوا
فيها
تمام تمام
المسلسل بشتغل عليه تقريبا سبع ثمان شهور
ما بيتبقاش ليا فيه غير اسمي اللي على
التاتيه فمش عارف ايه
تمام
عشان انا بعمل ثلاث حاجات في المسلسل لا
حلو حلو خلاص مسلسل برضو يلا حط اسمك فين
ما تبغى فيه ههه محمد كمان واحده من
الاشياء امي بتفرح يعني امي اكتر حاجه
بتفرحها هي وابويا الاسم ده
هكتبه لها لا لا اذا نحط طول المسلسل حطوا
تحت كده على الجنب طول مسلسل
بالشكل ده وانجح مع الناس يعني زي ما كنت
في الصفاره لطيف برضو يعني سرير قريب على
القلب تبغى تكون طيب
تقدر تعمل حاجات الراجل ما بيعملهاش يعني
الست بتحمل وتربيه وتكبر وتشتغل في نفس
الوقت انما في فعلا فعلا
واذكى انت عايزه تضيعيني مع الرجاله ههه
[موسيقى]
ده انت اتبهدلت يا ادم
شكرا
واضح جدا يعني
بس مستاهل الموضوع التحفظ
عنه تافه ابدا يعني
[موسيقى]
المهم
اكو ثلاث معاير
واحد واحد بس
وهو تافهه طيب لو قلت اسمه هتورطنا
[ضحك]
خلاص يعني وصلت القمه الان هلا ايه اللي
عملته فينا هذا رمضان انت اسطوره اسطوره
اسطوره اسطوره في هذا رمضان
[ضحك]
فعلا
فعلا فعلا
الضحك مثل ما شفتوا كيف ماخذ حيز محترم من
البرنامج لكن معها كمان يمكن في كثير كلام
جدي نجوم ردوا على الجدل فاجئونا باخبار
حصريه علقوا على انتقادات وغيره الكثير
كمان هو معك كم من نجوم اللي ظهروا معانا
التصريحات الحصريه والردود كانت هائله راح
نتابعها على اجزاء في سياق الحلقه خلونا
نشوف الان الجزء الاول
انا شايف ان اني اني اني احمد داش راجل
عامل يعني في نفس رمضان عنده مسلسل بطولته
على على شاشه قناه مهمه
كان عنده مسلسل بطوله احمد داش النهارده
مهم
وقصه الموضوع قائمه على محمد رمضان واحمد
باشا الراجل وابنه جعفر وابنه
انا مش شايف ان حتى لو حصل بعد ان اني اني
اللي حضرتك تقصديه ان منه قالت منه دي
اطيب واحده في العالم ممثله رائعه وانسانه
جميله وهي واحمد اصحابه واخوات
بس وان كان احيانا ممكن الواحد يخونه
التعبير او يخونه الكلام او يبقى طمعان في
شيء اكتر فيلاقي حاجه او هي بتقيسها
بالاقدميه كل ممثل من حقه ان هو يتمنى
ولكن دي في الاخر تعاقدات وبتاع ده لا
ينقص من منا ولا يزيد من احمد ولا ينقص من
احمد ولا يزيد منه الاتنين اصحاب واخوات
وزملاء في عمل ناجح وبينهم كل احترام انا
عارفه انه لبسته من قبل ولبسته مرتين لانه
فستان بحبه وما عندي مشكله يعني فستان
موجود عندي وبحبه بلبسه وما فيك ترد الناس
سمعت الكلام عن الجراه وما الجراه يعني
حتى انت شخصيتك بتذكر كلمات يعني اعتبروها
البعض جريئه يعني
ما اشوف انه اوفر ارجع اقول يعني انه ماني
شايفه انه في اي شيء بالعكس لو استمرون في
المتابعه راح يفهمون القصه راح يفهمون
مبررات كثيره بس المشاهد يعني ما يقدر
يحكم من اول حلقات فرصتي واتحقها واستحق
اليوم اني اكون موجوده واستحق اني اللي
اخذ البطوله
هذا يعني هذا مكاني الحمد لله والشكر
فماما خذته من احد ثاني بنفس الوقت خلي
الفرصه للشباب وللوجوه الجديده ما بيها اي
مشكله او خلل انه يطلع انه وجه جديد احنا
كنا زمان الجمهور بيتريق على الممثلات
اللي بيبقوا صاحيين من النوم شعرهم معمول
ميك اب وبيستحموا فدلوقتي الست واقعيه جدا
دي واحده عندها حدوته كبيره قوي فطبيعي
يبقى شكلها كده ما عندهاش وقت بقى لا تحط
ميك اب ولا حتى سوري يعني تعمل حواجبها هي
منى زكي دي من المدرسه الواقعيه المفرطه
هنرجع نشوف خالد يوسف خلاص مثلا نجم
النجوم رمضان دائما
لا انا العمليه مرهقه جدا جدا في حقيقه
هذه التغريده ايش اللي صاير والله بصراحه
انا اصلا ما اعرف من الايدان للامانه يعني
وما اعرف يعني دخلت على الاكاونت لقيت انه
هذا الاشياء منشوره فاستغربت
على اكاونتك انت لقيتها منشوره
هل احد مهكر حسابي وكاتب لهذه
بها بشخص الكريم ما اعرفها والله بعدين
دخلت على كاونتر لقيتها حاكي اشياء بعدين
معتذره بعدين حاكي اشياء وراح انسحبت فما
افتهم هاي المسكينه يعني عندها مشكله
الظاهر عائليه ماثر عليها وبعدين
فما شفت الموضوع يستاهل انه يحكي بصراحه
حضرتك ذكرت قلت انه صديقي وحبيبي ابو
راكان يعني عوده التعاون مع ناصر القصبي
بعد 12 سنه كان كيف كانت الكواليس بعد هذا
الغي اب يعني خصوصا انه في فتره كانت فيها
اخذ ورد وقيل وقالوا خلافات يعني
في خلافات هي خلافات في وجهات نظر على
الانتاج والعمل والشراكه وما شابه وهذه
تحصل في كثير من الشركات وكثير من
شركات كبرى بنوك وما شابه هي خلافات بسيطه
وفي مرحله عمريه معينه هذه منتهيه لكن بعد
العوده
حقيقه يعني كاننا امس يعني كان 11 سنه
اختزلت في فتره سبع شهور او ثمانيه شهور
ما حسينا باي شيء يعني يبقى هو عرفني وانا
اعرفه يعني احنا عارفين بعض
وهدفنا في النهايه ان هذه السفينه ان تصل
الى
المرفا او تصل الى بر الامان بشكل مناسب
وجيد عبد الله وناصر كيف يعني كان هذا
الشغل الشاغل لكن ابو راكان وعبد الله
اكبر من هذه الامور
مرحله متجاوزه وتم تجاوزها بكل اريحيه
وبكل بساطه
في اختيار ليله زاهر عشان تشاركك العمل
وطبعا يعني دائما في حديث كان عن خلافك مع
والدها الفنان الكبير احمد زاهر وقالوا
انه الاختيار ليله كان مفاجاه للجميع
وبعدين يعني انا شخصيا يعني وانا بتكلم مع
الفنان احمد زاهر وزوجته هدى كانوا
بيتكلموا كمان قديش انك انت كنت رائعه في
التعامل معاها وقديش انك انت احتضنتيها
فعليا هذا الاختيار كيف جاء
اولا ليلى كنت انا مختاراها من قبل ما
احمد يطلع في البرنامج ويقول ان في مشاكل
حتى انا نفسي
استغربت قوي انا واحمد عمران متخانقنا
عمري ما كان في بينا خناقه حتى قصاد بعض
كده
وزعقنا مع بعض فانا قلت اكيد اكيد حد وصل
له او حد قال له ده فبالتالي هو خد الخطوه
من غير ما يسالني فاهمه
بس
فلم ده حصل في الجموم قالوا لي طب انت
شايفه ايه يعني ليلى قلت لهم لا لا لا
ليلى هتيجي وليلى هتشتغل وبعدين دي مهنه
احنا يا جماعه احنا مش مش الممثلين ابدا
اللي بصفي حسابات شخصيه
شغلتي
مهنتي دي اكل عيشي دي دي حاجه
كنت بحلم بيها طول حياتي هي اللي عملتني
فهل هنا ابقى ست ادخل في شغلي اصل مين قال
وفلان عادوا لا لا لا وبالذات ان بجد بجد
انا ما بكرهوش انا مش عارفه هو جايب
الكلام ده منين الحاجه الوحيده بس اللي
قلتها له قلت له احمد قبل ما تقول اتاكد
لان ممكن انا انا حكايتي عدت انا ست ذكيه
وخبرتي بسني ممكن ده يحصل مع حد تاني ما
يبقاش عنده خبرتي او ما يبقاش زيي فهماني
فتحصل بجد مشكله هو بس عشان يعني التوضيح
هو جاي الوقت انه تم استبعاده من عمل
بسببك يعني
فانت بتقولي انه لا هذا الشيء ما صار حتى
لا لا
اوكي لكن انا اتكلم في نقطه اني اشوف هذا
جزء من الواقع يعني هذا كانت قاعده بنات
وكنا قاعد نتكلم عن شيء معين وان قالت
الكلمه بغض النظر صح ولا غلط لكن انا من
باب انه هذا اول شيء واقع هذا البوست اللي
انت كاتبه وبترد انه في على المغرضين
واللي بيحطوا كلام على لسانك وانه كل
الاحترام والتقدير للممثلين السوريين وما
الى ذلك ايش صار اللي خلاك توني تكتب هذا
البوست اللي صار هو انه صار في كلام
كتب كلام عن لساني انا مش قايله يعني
بكل مقابلات اللي مرقت فيها بهالفتره
الاخيره ولا مره انا جرحت ولا مره قلت انا
يا ريتني الممثلين السوريين عم بياخدوا من
تربه عم بياخدوا من دربي عم بياخدوا ادوار
البطوله ولا مره قلتها من زمان كان في بيت
موضوع معين وخلص وانتهى وخلص الموضوع
حقيقه النعجه نقول قديش كان ممتع حقيقه
الشغل على هذه المقابلات وتقديمها لكم
ومثل ما كلكم بتعرفوا يعني قبل الهواء مع
الفنانين في تجهيزات فتعالوا اوريكم شويه
كواليس من تحضير المقبلات مع ضيوفنا
ايوه عليلي الصوت
ايوه الانسه مع
يلا احنا الان دقائق وحنكون معك على
الهواء قلبوا لي انا جاسم بيلعبوا لي
الكاميرات بس ان شاء الله دقائق حنكون معك
على الهواء انا شايفتك وشايفه الجمال
وشايفه اللون الحلو وشايفه الورد اللي
وراك اللي ماشي مع اللبس
برهوم
برهوم برهوم على التليفون
زوجاتك
انت تعمل لهم تعمل لهم فوان كول يعني
تجمعهم
زوم عشان نختصر
ط نفسك
احنا لايف ولي السالفه طب ده احنا لو لايف
ايش حيصير حتكون مره متورط صح
والله لان قاعد حسن مكاني
ايش اخبارك
الحمد لله امين ساره ايوه
بالظبط مين رفضتك كيف مهره رفضتك
كيف
العبره والنهايه
[موسيقى]
عامله ايه وحشتيني انت اللي وحشاني ايش
الابداع هذا المسلسل
رهيب دورك رهيب انت رهيبه
انا بحبك وانا قلبي حبيبتي والله طالعه
خرافيه احمد
الو هاي يا احمد
ازيك يا احمد انا بتفائل فيك كل رمضان
والله لانك
والله بطير من اللي قبله هنكون معك على
الهواء حبيبتي
خلال دقائق فخليك معانا
يا خالد كيف حالك
الحمد لله تمام سامعاني كويس كل عام وانت
بالف خير يا رب
ربنا يخليك طب ميرسي سمعاني لان انا بتكلم
من الموبايل مش من اللابتوب حاسس هيبقى مش
حلو وكل الحكايه على بعضها
لا لا لا
محمد عبده الله
تسلميلي يلا
على الهوا ما اصدق
كيف حالك
ههه مش عايزه اضحك عشان سنتي طايره
يا سلام
كده لاحظت انك انت محل اخرك كثير حنكون
الان معاك على الهواء سريعين وحنرجعك
للتصوير ان شاء الله سريعا بشكركم جدا على
على تحت تحت الفرصه الجميله دي ليا وليا
الشرف ابدا ابدا اصلا احمد ترى انت لسه مش
على الهواء انا وانت بنتكلم كده بس
ديناميمه تحت الهوا
يا حبيبتي يا حبيبتي كل سنه وحضرتك طيبه
والله يا ساره انا عملت جيمس بوند يعني ما
كانش عمل اللي انا عملته النهارده عشان
الحق جيت في 20 في اقل من 20 دقيقه من
مدينه الانتاج الاعلامي والله طب ما انت
ما تعملي ده
بالبوكينج يا دكتوره مش هعمل حرمت خلاص
حصل خير الحمد لله لحقت هنا ولحقتي هنا
يلا المهم ان انا جيت يلا ايه بركه رمضان
الجميله ايمان ده كله يطلع منك يا ايمان
ده كله يطلع منك
لسه ما عملتش حاجه
عم تسمعوني منين
سمعتك منيحه وبتفرج على الزن وبتفرج على
الثمن عندك في الجاليري عندنا او في غرفه
التحكم في واحد انت الكرش تبع حياته وحب
وعمره كله
فبيسلم عليك برضه بس رافض انه يعني يقول
اسمه صراحه وخلاص
فبده يكون سكره ادميرو ما بده كده يعبر لك
خلاص اهلا وسهلا بصفصه الملكه
سمعاني اهلا اهلا
دخلنا هواء ولا لسه يا قطه لا لسه لسه يا
ملكه
فايز يا فايز
اهلا بالشيخه ساره اهلا وسهلا هلا هلا
وغلا يا مرحبا ومسهلا ومقربه احنا بس
حبينا نسلم عليك قبل الهوى ونتاكد انه كله
تمام والان خلال دقيقه حنقول على الهواء
مباشره معاك
جاهزين
[موسيقى]
انا شفت كمان يمكن الناقده ماجده خير الله
كاتبه كانت انك اسوء شخصيه في المسلسل
وانه انت عامله شخصيه الشخص
اللي مغترب اللي جايبه انه بطريقه فيها
تخلف عقلي وعبط قديش جرحك هذا الكلام يعني
يمكن جاتك انتقادات بس هذا حسيتيه جارح
اكيد
انا عايزه اقول لحضرتك حاجه استاذه ماجده
قبل كده مدحت فيا وقالت عليا ان انا ممثله
كويسه وممثله موهوبه فانا مش متضايقه من
الانتقاد ده زي ما قلت لك بالعكس ده انا
هتعلم منه وابقى احسن بسببه فانا مش
متضايقه منه ومش متضايقه من اي حد قال اي
حاجه على الدور ده لان انا عارفه ده طبيعي
انت ساعات بتعملي دور حلو قوي وممكن بعد
كده تعملي دور مش احلى حاجه لك او مش لايق
عليك فانا انا متقبله جدا الاراء دي
وبالعكس انا بتعلم منها وانا بشكرها ان هي
قالت كده علشان اتعلم من النقد ده ودائما
بشوف ان النقد بناء يعني انا هبقى احسن
بسببك فانا مش متضايقه وبالعكس هي قالت
عليا كلام قبل كده حلو واكيد هتقول كلام
ان شاء الله حلو قريب
يعني يا ميان بيعكس نضج يعني صراحه انتوا
بتجراوا جدا انا نسيتها خلاص يعني انا انا
بحاول بحاول اتعافى من سيد لان سيد كان
عامل لي مشكله
سيد كان عايش معايا ثلاث شهور اللي هو وقت
التصوير كنت انا وسيد بس عايشين في بيت
لوحدنا انا ما شفتش اولادي ما شفتش
اصدقائي ما خرجتش من البيت كنت بخرج بس
اجيب اكل اجيب اجيب حاجه وارجع تاني عايش
في البيت انا وسيد ببص في المرايه بلاقي
سيد بكلم سيد بذاكر وانا سيد طول الوقت
انا مركز كل التركيز ويا رب الحمد لله
يعني النتيجه الحمد لله يعني طلعت الحمد
لله على قد المجهود في عندك انت واحده
قالت لك انه دكتورك يبدو هو نفس دكتور
هيفاء وهعلقك على صوره لك في انستقرام انت
رديتي عليها وقلتي لها جربي نفس الدكتور
شوفي اذا بتطلعي تشبهينا بس انه انا
كفنانه انه كل شويه تعليق وتنمر على موضوع
التجميل ولو ما كل الناس يعني الناس
العاديه ستات البيوت ما بتطلع الشاشه
واللي ما هي الناس اللي بيشوفوها كل وقتهم
بتعمل تجميل فلي ش فليش انتم عم تتنمروا
على ممثله وفنانه هي لازم تكون دائما
بالموت الازياء وبالشكل سيره بتقول انك
انت ما كثير داخل في عالم السوشيال ميديا
انت ما عندك واتساب كمان يا جورج كيف عايش
كيف معي هعيش معانا على هذا الكوكب
مضبوط والله عايش عايش عم بتنفس عادي
وسعيد اكيد مروج اكيد اسعد منا انا من
ناحيه انك انت مروق
والله انا عايش يعني انا عايش مع الطبيعه
بحب الطبيعه كتير بحب البحر بحب الشجر
وعايش ببلتي هون بالبترون على الفيسبا
تبعي وعلى البسكليت تبعي فانا جدا سعيد
بالحياه الطبيعيه
رائع يعني انت بتعطينا مثال وبتذكرنا انه
في اسلوب مختلف للحياه السريعه اللي نحن
صرنا فيها والكلام هذا كله انت حضرتك عندك
تعليق او تحبي تضيفي شيء على هذا الموضوع
حقول حاجه واحده بس دايما الشجر المثمره
بيحدفوها بالطوب انا فاكره كويس جدا ان كل
الاعمال اللي انا عملتها اللي كانت ناجحه
وعملت بوم من اول اسبوع اتقال عليها نفس
الكلام
وهفكرك ونفس الكلام ده حصل في سبق الاصرار
وحكايه حياه والكابوس وحدو تمره نفس ده
بالضبط بالملي بدي اسالكم كده شويه اسئله
بس على المواضيع هل عندكم قضايا مرفوعه
عليكم انتم رافعين قضايا على احد
انا رافعه انت رافعه قضيه على مين
القضايا مالتنا اللي يعني في قانون ياخذ
مجرى
يعني
في القضيه لود اعشقوه اخر قضيه الشكوى
اللي مقدمينه اخر قضيه كانت
تحريض الصحافه
اذكر الدوله تحريض صحافه خليجيه علي انا
في واتسابات ومسجات بين الصحفي والشخص
اللي انا رافعه عليه
الشخصة المعنيه قصدك بالقضيه
وحده وحده هي لانه نشوف بعض المقاطع
ظلموني او اقطعوا رزقي سالفه الرزق هذه من
الله لا بيجي ولا بيدك واللي بيظلم يظلم
نفسه من ايده هذي شغله شغله ثانيه انا لو
بطلب اقطع الرزق انا ترجيت عبد الوهاب
العيسى وهو حي يرزق موجود دشيت مكتبه في
بوتيكات وترجيته رجوى انه يدخلها بوتيكات
وكنت ماسكه تلفوني سنابها واقول له أشوف
شوفي شلون مسرحيتها شوف العرض تكفى خلاص
خلاص ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ما دار
يومين الا وقعوها بوتيكات ابسط قطعه رزق
يا ساره انا من التوب سيلفري في بوتيكات
واول وحده وقعت عقد بوتيكات ولذي كلمه
مسموعه لله الحمد في بوتيكات لو انا بقطع
هالرزق كان باب وتيكات وقطعت الرزق وقلت
سكره واكلتها صح ولا لا والله يا ساره
شوفي احنا في الايام الفضيله ما فيها
والله العظيم انه بيني وبين يعني في نفسي
وبيسمعوني اقول حتى ما صار في خط رجعه
ما اتركوا اثر جميل ان الواحد يرد وفيه خط
رجعه ورا طقه طقه ورا طقه طقه ورا طقه هذي
خلاص يعني ذاك اليوم نسولف حق شهاب اقول
له يمكن الغلطه الاولى اعديها الثانيه
اعديها
واسامح يصير بين الاهل وبين الحبايب ماكو
مشكله بس لكن في حدود وفي خط رجعه تصير
ملوتنا المصري ما كانش موجود محمد علي
اللي جابه من الهند دي بقى فزلكه من طراز
رفيع يعني يعني اعرض لك تغريده ثانيه
للناقد رجا ساير المطيري كان بيقول فيها
انه طاش المشروع يجب ان يستمر انه مهما
كان مستواه ولازم يتحول
لزيت لايف اللي مستمر صار له خمسين سنه
وناجح جدا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وطبعا حول العالم ايضا هل ممكن نتوقع انه
في جزء ثاني ويستمر هذا المشروع
العلم عند الشيوخ حقيقه يعني هم من جمعنا
وهم من
اسسوا طاش العوده وهذا الفكره
العلم عند ابو ناصر تحديدا يعني انا اتوقع
ابو ناصر
والشيخ ابراهيم انا قلت في بدايه اللقاء
انه طاش هو اصبح جزء من الموروث الشعبي
السعودي لا اتوقع انه عبد الله السدحان او
ناصر القصبي في هذه المرحله او بهذا العمر
بحاجه الى شهره او
اضواء او ما شابه لا احنا المهم عندنا
كفنانين صادقين برساله لنحملها هو ارضاء
المتلقيته وكفيت ولا تبيني اكمل لا يعني
انت وفيت
كفيتني اجابه واضحه انه اذا بتتكلموا على
جزء ثاني ولا لا الصراحه هل ناقشوكم طيب
ما تكلمنا حقيقه
لا لا لكن انا مثل ما تفضلت انا
همي هو المتلقي همي هي الاسره يعني طاش
مثل ولا بدي التواجد واعيد انه يعني لو
جو لو قالوا لك الشي
وخ في
ثاني السنه الجايه حتقول اوكي
لا يمكن بقول لهم انتم فصلوا وانا البس
لكن حيكون لي بعض الشروط البسيطه اللي هي
في النص
[موسيقى]
من بعد كمل اعمال اللي تكلمنا عنها
واستضيفنا نجومها وتابعناها احنا كمان
شخصيا حبينا السنه نكرر تجربه استفتاء
النقاد اللي عملناه السنه الماضيه وسالنا
مجموعه من النقاد عن ارائهم في الاعمال
الدراميه في هذا الموسم خلونا نسمع سوا
مين برايي النقاد كان افضل ممثل وافضل
ممثله
افضل ممثل ما زال قصي خوري هو نجم
الشباك باسم يخور في العربجي وعبد فهد فيه
النار بالنار الفنان كادي النبوي للدور
الصعب والمريء بالتفاصيل في مسلسل رساله
الامام
فضلت مسلسل الزند فوجدت ان تيم حسن هو
الاكثر ادهاشا على مستوى الوطن العربي في
في دورة
وجورج خباز وفايز قزق وجاسم النبهان اختار
الفنان اللبناني
بمسلسل النار بالنار والفنان العبد فهد
ايضا عن نفس المسلسل والفنان دياب بمسلسل
تحت الوصايه في محمد رمضان وخالد النبوي
لكن في رايي برضو افضل ممثل هو محمد رمضان
قادر يمشي مع الشخصيه بتدعيتها
بكل حاجه
[موسيقى]
حقيقه منى زكي عن دورها في مسلسل تحت
الوصايه
خليني اضيف ايضا ورد الخالدي للموت ثلاثه
منى زكي عن تحت الوصايه وجدت ان تقدم اداء
متميزا كارث بشار
منى زكي
ومنى واصف
وهي عبد السلام الى منازع منى زكي اكيد
والفنانه السوريه كارثه بشار عن دور مريم
في النار بالنار وورد الخال عن دورها في
مسلسل للموت 3
من رمضان جات منى زكي بتحت
راى النقاد في افضل الممثلين المساعدين
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن يماني ومؤيد الثقفي محمد اكبر
ثابته
وحسين الحداد الفنان فتحي عبد الوهاب
بشخصيتين مهمين في سوق الكانتو والكتيبه
101 الفنان احمد عيد وهو ايضا من يعني
العناصر المميزه هذا الموسم في عمله نادره
شخصيه مسعود الفنان دياب في شخصيه صالح في
تحت الوصايه انا سياره بالزنا الذئب
العاصي من مسلسل
تحت من مسلسل جعفر العمده من غير ما افكر
اقدر اقول الفنان حمزه العيلي في مسلسل
الامام الشافعي
انس طياره كان يعني ممثل استطاع ان يقدم
اداء متميزا في دوره نورس باشا في مسلسل
الزنك
[موسيقى]
الزهراني
بشاير سلطان
وساره صلاح مي كساب افضل ممثل دور تاني في
مسلسل
جعفر العمده والفنانه مها نصار عن ادوارها
التلاته وخصوصا تحت الوصايه معنى نصار هلا
صدقي بشير فنانه الجميله مي كساب لدى
توحيد في مسلسل سفر الممثل السعوديه وايضا
الممثله السعوديه ريم العلي في مسلسل من
هو ولدنا ايضا استطاعه ان تقدم اداء وانا
اجدها ان هي افضل
يعني افضل ممثله في المسلسل بالكامل
اعمال كثيره ضخمه انتاجيا واخرى جماهيريا
ومجهودات جباره خلتنا كمان نسال النقاد
اصحابنا مين برايهم كان افضل مخرج
[موسيقى]
سامر البرقاوي
وكريم الشناوي
وعلي بدر رضا وخالد الحلفاوي ليش حقه في
مسلسل
الامام الشافعي
في مسلسل سفر برلك
محمد شاكر خضير مخرج مسلسل تحت الوصايه
بلا شك يعني يقدم هذه الملحمه التاريخيه
في مسلسل سفر برلك بالتاكيد يستحق ان يكون
هو افضل مخرج
بس انا كمان كانت مليئه بضيوف شرف نجوم
غير متوقعين بادوار ثانويه نجمت بشكل واسع
عن كل هذولا وغيرهم سالنا النقاد مين
برايهم افضل واكبر مفاجاه في رمضان السنه
[موسيقى]
المفاجاه حقيقه هي عوده
ناصر قصبه عبد الله السدحان بعد انقطاع 12
سنه
[موسيقى]
الفنانه هاله صدقي هاله صدقي عامله دور
مهم دايما بتطلع ارستقراض لكن طالعه بلدي
بشكل جميل فيها الكوميديا وفيها الاكشن
فيها كل اللي احنا بنقول التوابل بتاعتها
من بعيد كده بتفكرنا بزينه بالنسبه له هو
ممثل السعوديه عبد الرحمن اليماني يعني
وجدت ممثل لدي طاقه عاليه طاقه ادائيه
عاليه ممكن ان يكون يعني في المستقبل
الفنان له يشار له بالبنان
بنجي لعند الفعل اهم افضل عمل خلينا نسمع
ايش قالوا
[موسيقى]
واخيرا
لقصي خولي ونادين
وايضا مسلسل جعفر العمده لكني
عميل الى
واخيرا ابتسم ايها الجنرال من الافضل
لجراه طرحه السياسي وسقف العالي السابعه
وكامل العقل وبلغت نهائي مسلسل تحت
الوصايا رغم ان هو اتعرض في النصف الثاني
لكن قدر ان هو يحقق نجاح كبير لكن
بالتاكيد من مسلسلات النصف الاول الصفاره
والهرش السبعه
وعمله نادره اعمال ايضا تستحق ان تتقدم
على المستوى الفني
ومسلسل النار بالنار افضل مسلسل السنه دي
هو جعفر العمده مسلسل الزند هو افضل هذه
المسلسلات
في الاقل جوده والنقاد في الكليب الجاي
حيث سمعوكم ارائهم في الفنانين اللي كانوا
الاسوا برايهم في رمضان
[موسيقى]
اسوء ممثل
بالتاكيد هم كثر يعني
مقارنه مع
الجيدين في الساحه
الرمضانيه لكن اعتقد انه احمد ايراج لم
يحالف الحظ في مسلسل حياه المثاليه اسف
مضطرين ندي محمد سعد جائزه اسوا ممثل لسوء
تقدير وسوء استعداده لهذا الدور لم يحقق
اي نجاحها يذكر سعود مشاري
وفهد
ممثل فهم كثر ولكن انا بختار صالح بكريم
المسلسل تغيير جو والذي يقوم بدمر فارس لم
يترك
بصمه لم نشعر بها محمد سعد هو الاسوا
السنه
[موسيقى]
الغامدي لم يحالفها الحظ ايضا في مسلسل
حياه المثاليه لم يشفع لها هذا التاريخ
العريض جدا الذي قدمته في الساحل الفنيه
واسوا م يعني هذا العام بتفوز فيها وتتوج
نبينا من نصيب
اسوا ممثله الفنانه ريهام حجاج لم تقنع اي
حد
بالبطوله اللي هي بتعملها
وهذه كانت ارائهم في العمل الاسوا
[موسيقى]
مسلسل على ما يبدو دفعه لندن اسوا مسلسل
بطوله محمد سعد محدش بيسمعني اما اسوا عمل
فنافسه في ذلك
23 عمل سيء جدا ولا يستحق ان يعرض لانه لم
يقدم اي جديد
طبعا هذه اراء النقاد واحنا نحب نشكر كل
اللي ظهروا معانا في هذه الفقره وشاركونا
بارائهم وهم عبد الرحمن الناصر ليلى احمد
ومحمد عبد الرحمن واحمد سعد الدين ورحاب
ظاهر وفاطمه عبد الله وعباس حايك شكرا
جزيلا لهم من تفاعلكم
مشاهدينا احنا السنه كمان حبينا نعمل شيء
مختلف يعني وبدل ما بس نسال النقاد حبينا
كمان نسالكم انتم مشاهدينا وعبر كل
منصاتنا سالناكم مين برايكم انتم كان
الافضل سالناكم في كل مكان فيسبوك تويتر
انستجرام كله يعني والافضل برايكم كان في
فئه افضل الممثل في المراتب الاولى او
الثلاثه الاولى جاء محمد رمضان عن جعفر
العمده باسم ياخور عن العربجي ومكسيم خليل
عن ابتسم ايها الجنرال لكن الاصوات الاعلى
راحت للنجم محمد رمضان اللي اخترتوه افضل
ممثل في الموسم وبالنسبه لافضل ممثله في
المراتب الثلاثه الاولى كانت في كاريس
بشار عن النار بالنار هاله صدقي عن جعفر
العمده ومنى زكي عن تحت الوصايه والاصوات
الاغلب راحت للنجمه منى زكي اللي بتقدم
اداء مبهر حقيقه والدليل انه اصلا المسلسل
دخل سباق في النصف الثاني من رمضان ومتصدر
الترند والمشاهدات والاشادات اما افضل
مسلسل فباغلبيه كبيره جدا وصراحه زي ما
توقعنا جعفر العمده في المركز الاول كافضل
مسلسل بحسب ارائكم
[موسيقى]
بنزينه زينه زعلانه منكم فعلا في خلاف ولا
لا لا ما اعرفش لا ما اعرفش والله هي انا
ما اعرفش ممكن تكون عندها حاجه او ممكن
تكون مش موجوده انا ما اعرفش يعني ايه هو
هو بيدعو كل واحد مننا لشخص يعني كل واحد
يوصل له لشخصه ممكن تبقى
شخصيا اه انت انت شخصيا ما بينك وبين اخي
لافيا لا طبعا ليه خلاف ليه اعوذ بالله
بالعكس يعني الست بطلت مسلسلي وعامله شغل
جميل جدا وانا مبسوط بالشغل ولا بالعكس
ليه خلاف اعوذ بالله الجده المستمر على
موضوع زينه انت قلت انه ما عندك اي مشكله
مع زينه والكلام هذا كله زينه طلعت في
برنامج الان والتصريحات عمليه كل مكان
تقول ما راح اشتغل مره ثانيه مع محمد سامي
خلينا خلينا ننجح في مسلسلنا ونتبسط
بنجاحه شفنا نجاحه مسلسلنا وبعدين نبقى
نشوف قصه زينه
[موسيقى]
جدا
مش هتشتغل مع محمد سامي تاني انا انا في
الاخر عملنا مسلسل ناجح وربنا سبحانه
وتعالى كلامنا فيه ونجحنا واتبسطنا وعملنا
شغل كويس وهي نجحت عملت دور كويس ربنا
يسعدها بنجاحها ويبسطها بنجاحها وده قرار
يخصها هي هي هي اكيد لها وجهه نظر انا
بحترمها
كممثلين او مشاركين بالعمل ما في حد منا
يقبل انه اي امراه يعني ما نقول عراقيه او
غيرها اي امراه تتعرض للاساء ثم بالك انك
انا كراق عراقيه اقبل على هذا الشيء بس ما
حسيتي للحظه انه لا ممكن الموضوع ينفهم
غلط انه ليش ليش العراقيات طالعين في كدور
عاملات في عند مثلا كويتيات
امانه ما كان الموضوع مركز على هذا الجزء
طبعا يعني في كذا ريفرنس كان بذهني طب في
رفرنس جدليه معينه بتقدر تحب تقول لنا هي
الحقيقه انا ضليت فتره طويله يعني مهتم
بشخصيه الرئيس صدام حسين انه يعني هو رجل
عنده كاريزما قويه جدا
اثنين هو الشخص ممكن يكون يعني غضوب وحاسم
بدرجه يعني تصل الى حدود قصوى من القسوه
يعني بيبقى يعني ردود فعله قويه وحاسمه
وممكن يدمر كل شيء حواليه
واحيانا بيبقى شخص متبسط ومستمع ومتامل
وممكن يكون صاحب نكته كمان بنفس الوقت فهي
الشخصيه يعني الحياه
غنيه جدا
في النظر طبعا عن موقفي انا السياسي من
موقفي معروف يعني انا كنت يعني على الدوام
ضد سياسات ضد غزو الكويت بالتاكيد احنا
قاعد نسوي حالات الطلاب حياتهم الطبيعيه
كثر ما هي الدراسه نشوف الاكشن وبالنهايه
احنا دراما لازم نسوي شويه نفتح فيها
الخطوط هذه مبين شلون الخليجي او العربي
او اي شخص يسافر لندن دراسه طبعا عنده
اشياء بره فيها اكشن فيها حب فيها اشياء
سياسيه فيها دينيه فيها ايا كان انه حياه
يعني واكيد تابعت كمان الجدل اللي على
الموضوع انه الاساءه للمراه العراقيه
والعراق تاج على راسنا واحنا نغار على
العراق وما ما نوضع احد يغلط عليها هلا
المسلسل انتهى
احنا طبعا بنتكلم عن قصه طلاق وسنين طويله
موضوع الطلاق
بصي انت وشك حلو عليا بس لانه انا انا
طبعا مش عايزه اقول لك انا تعبانه ومجهده
قد ايه لاني انا من الساعه ثمانيه الصبح
في الشارع وطبعا نازله من سته ونايمه خمسه
لانه احنا الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
الطلاق تم
خلص الموضوع الحمد لله
والنهارده بالتحديد
رحت غيرت اسمي في الرقم القومي همم الاي
دي بتاعي يعني وغيرت الباسبور وغيرت كل
الاوراق يعني كل الاوراق القديمه اترمت
والنهارده كل اوراق جديده بس اليوم لما من
اول ما بدا عرض المسلسل الناس كلها كانت
بتقول هذا مسلسل جريء جريء جريء انصدمنا
من حجم الشفافيه والجراه في الحوار وفي
وصف يعني خلينا نقول اللي هي بتكون زي
المناوشات اللي بتصير بين اللبنانيين
والسوريين وحسسنا انها يعني فعلا واقعيه
يعني اللي بيصير في المشاهد لما ان قرات
السكريبت ما حسيت انه اوف هذا الكلام جريء
ما عمرنا عملنا شيء قبل كده زي كده
[موسيقى]
على فكره انا قلت الساعات لو طبقت في
التصوير في التصوير يومين او تلاته ورا
بعض ما اقدرش اصوم فيهم لاني باخذ ادويه
ادويه
كل اللي انا قلته ده ايوه كاتبين اصلها ما
بتصومش في رمضان لما بتشتغل
ممتاز غاده انك انت الان وضحتي هذا
الموضوع لانه العناوين فعلا كلها اجتزقت
جزء معين يعني فجيد انك انت وضحت هذا
الشيء
وهذا المتطرف من دين غير دينك وممكن بعض
الناس ياخذوا هذا الموضوع بحساسيه ما وترك
هذا الموضوع
جدلي جدا زكريا منه طبيعي هذا الانسان منو
طبيعي
وكم هناك من اشخاص غير طبيعيين في الحياه
يعني بنظام الحياه ككل
فهذه الحاله الاستثنائيه عم جسدها هي
موجوده بارض الواقع
التخيل ولا التصور هي من ارض الواقع
الديني بتقولي لي مثلا عند المسيحيين
لانه ما في انسان فوق راسه خيمه في كثير
ناس عنده عند الطرفين هيك وهيك
[موسيقى]
تحضير كل حلقه من حلقات تفاعلكم بياخد
مننا الكثير من الجهد عشان نقدم لكم
الافضل دائما وفي رمضان الجاهل والجهد
السنه هذه كان مضاعف خصوصا انه اظلينا
عليكم لمده ساعه يوميا بدل نصف ساعه في
المقطع القادم سامحنا لنفسنا كده نهني
نفسنا على الموسم ونشكر نفسنا كمان على
المجهود ونوريكم بالمره جزء من كواليس
العمل على الحلقه
[موسيقى]
طيب نيجي الان لمقطع البلوتوث المفضل في
الحلقه وللعلم اللي بقراوا امامكم الان
انا ما قريته قبل الحلقه اني اطلع عليه
ولا على المقطع اللي راح تشوفوه الان زين
السنه الماضيه طبعا فاجاتني في نهايه اخر
حلقه في رمضان من الكواليس والسنه محضره
لي مفاجاه ثانيه على ما يبدو انا مضطره
اني اقرا هذا المقطع واتفرج معكم للمره
الاولى المقطع اللي راح تشوفوه الان من
مقابلات حضرتوها وشفتوها وعنوانه خروجي عن
النص على الهواء الله يستر
مشاهدينا خلينا تبعنا انا
جورج خلينا نتفق اتفاق لانك انت من الاول
بتقول لي استاذه استنى بتقولي استاذه
بتقول لي مدام دحين بتقولي سيده الكريمه
خلاص ساره عشان انا بقول لك جورج ولا اقعد
اقول لك لازم استاذ جورج كمان اوكي ساره
اوكي اوكي
هي الشخصيه لها كاريزما رهيبه يعني صراحه
وبعدين وانت واقف ما شاء الله يعني مع
طولك وكذا واللبس وتصير بتطالع في كل
الزملاءك كده على تحت وكده ففعلا بتحس انك
انت الكبير
والدور كده فعلا له كاريزما كبيره اسمع
انا بدات كاني بتكلم كاني بغازلك جمال
حبيبه قلبي يا ساره
[موسيقى]
كامله تتزوج عمرك كم يعني
[ضحك]
مقلوبه عشان اقدر مقلب مقلبك كده
انا حاسه انه حاسه انه انا وانت عاملين
سيشن تيرابي الان على الهواء ههه
شبه البودكاست اللي بتعمله نادين يعني انا
وانت حنفتح قلوبنا وانا هحكي لك على زواجي
وانت راح تحكي لي على الموضوع
[موسيقى]
احمد مظهر ده طوله 165 سم
يعني حضرتك اطول مني
هو الحقيقه يعني يا خالد لو انت عرفت طول
الحقيقي ما كنت هتقول الجمله هذه لانه
احمد مظهر اطول مني بكثير الحقيقه يعني ما
شاء الله عليك كيف محافظه على هذا الجسم
ما شاء الله عليك الملابس
بعمل رياضه كتير
باكل كثير وبعمل رياضه كتير مع بعضهم
كم طولك يا ورده بس اكيد انا طول المتر
و75 ونص
للاخير يا غاده كيف ما شاء الله بتفضلي
حلوه عشان نفسيتي كويسه
حلو الجواب ده كلنا بنقول طب والله لو انا
يعني نفسيتي انا نفسي تكون كويسه كمان يا
غاده على كده هحاول اخلي نفسيتي كويسه
شايفاك دلوقتي انت حلوه ههه خلاص اسمع يا
غاده انت احسن مسلسل في رمضان وانت عشره
نجمات كل شيء انتي خلاص انا انت نجمتي 10
على 10 انت الان خلاص
[موسيقى]
يبدو مكتبوا بالمقطع اللي شفتوه لانه
بيقولوا لي الان انه في مقطع اخر وهذا عاد
عنوانه صار في الحمام في الكاميرا هذا
اكيد كارت
والله طالعه ايش حاطه ميك اب يا اسماء مش
عارفه يا عمري ما أنت مش فاهمه انا كيف
ماشيه طيب انت
ما انا فاهمه بس عشان التصوير اوكي بس
لازم تعملوا لي انا ماني سمعته احمد
ليه عملنا
عيدي لي موضوع الجميله علشان زملائي اللي
بيشككوا فيها
ان شاء الله هيكون احلى من العمده ولا ايش
تتوقع
يكون كويس
مسابقه تاريخيه سابقه تاريخيه زينه تعزمنا
على قهوه
فتحت المحفظه يا زينه
الدنيا رمضان اخيرا فتحت المحفظه
زي ما عودتكم كل ما نواجه اي تحديات طبعا
ايش
نوتيلا مع الصيام لانه مش قادره اروح اخذ
وجبه لانه
عشان تشوفوا حجم الجريمه
يا سلام يا سلام
المهم
ايه عمري والله
العظيم طالعه حلوه لا صدق
الله
بتاخدوني انا بالمره
ولو
رولا
ضغوط علي شديده من غرفه الكنترول كلهم
بحيوك وبيسلموا عليك وبشده وتحديدا طبعا
كمان في عندي فريق عمل تفاعلكم الاعداد
يعني زينه وسلام ينقل لك محبتهم الشديده
كمان
لا يا انت تقول لي انا هلا بالشيخه ساره
وتروح تقول لي زينه هلا بزينه زينه
الشيخ ساره والزين ساره والشيخه زينه
والزينه زينه لا لا لا زينه غلط زينه غلط
ههه
[موسيقى]
المقصود منه التشويه صورتي لكن انا انسانه
بس يعني احب اقول لكم متزنه هذه اشياء
يعني
جوانب خلينا نقول مظلمه
المقاطع بس على العموم مشاهدينا احنا
وصلنا لختام حلقه رمضان تفاعلكم في اجازه
ونعود ونلقاكم قريبا ان شاء الله في امان
الله وكل عام وانتم بالف الف الف خير